hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta emisión vamos a ir
hasta chile país que está viviendo un
proceso político y social histórico y es
que 19 meses después de las masivas
protestas sociales que estallaron en el
año 2019 los chilenos fueron a las urnas
durante el 15 y el 16 de mayo pasado y
lo hicieron para elegir a los 155
representantes de la convención
constituyente que estarán encargados de
escribir la nueva constitución del país
que va a reemplazar a la vigente en la
actualidad desde la dictadura de augusto
pinochet estamos hablando de un hecho
histórico para esta nación sudamericana
que comienza de esta manera a escribir
un nuevo capítulo de su historia y los
candidatos independientes lograron una
importante representación al obtener
casi un tercio de la composición de este
órgano destinado a escribir la nueva
carta magna órgano que tiene 77 mujeres
y 78 hombres nos acompaña jennifer meyer
quien fue electa para integrar
precisamente esta convención ella es
abogada especializada en derechos
humanos mujeres familias e infancias
además es feminista y activista
fue electa como constituyente
independiente de la coalición apruebo
dignidad por coquimbo una de las 16
regiones que conforman chile ubicadas en
el norte del país
jennifer media muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
hola santiago muestran gracias por la
invitación bueno sin y ver como mujer no
es una mujer también como feminista
lesbiana abogada experta en derechos
humanos activistas y campesina cuáles
son las principales demandas que
representan hoy que consideran
necesarias y más urgentes para el país
si mira en nuestro país sufre además de
un problema de memoria muy grande porque
digamos no venimos de proveedores del
pasado también un problema de
descentralización importante tú lo
dijiste yo soy resultante de una zona
norte del país por lo tanto para
nosotras es muy importante ir a poner
temas de descentralización y autonomía
regional que impacten definitivamente en
un mejor desarrollo de nuestras zonas
tanto en las zonas costeras como en las
zonas rurales nosotros necesitamos
contar con una mayor autonomía y con
soluciones más eficientes que nos
permitan también poder optar a un mejor
desarrollo en el país asimismo queremos
que también las mujeres al estar en la
mitad de la convención constitucional
vamos a llevar una agenda feminista
bastante expuesta para que la nueva
constitución que nos fija a todas ya
todos en y les pueda efectivamente estar
representativa de diversas realidades y
vivimos las mujeres en este país y que
nos lleven a superar desigualdades
estructurales que aún afronta muy
sensibles y por otra parte temas
sectoriales
el agua que también son muy importantes
debido a la sequía que sufrimos ya hace
mucho tiempo
ahora el hecho de que usted siendo como
decían previamente mujer activista
feminista también sea una de las
encargadas de redactar la nueva
constitución de chilenos habla de un
cambio en la sociedad chilena hay un
antes y un después quizás tras aquel
estallido social de 2019
y definitivamente creemos que después de
la noche del 16 de mayo efectivamente
estamos hablando de un cambio quizás
haber puesto fin a la transición que es
que le tardó 30 años y que llegó a la
clase política a alejarse de la
ciudadanía y principalmente del mundo
social organizado en este país y que
dejó a todas las que antes digamos a la
deriva especialmente durante la revuelta
pero también durante lavandería y eso
hoy día ha reflejado que mucha gente ha
votado por ciudadanía independiente con
un fuerte arraigo territorial activistas
sociales con largas trayectorias que
hemos trabajado en los distintos
espacios siempre sociales pero sin
pertenecer a esta clase política que de
alguna manera le dio la espalda a la
ciudadanía durante todo este tiempo por
lo tanto yo creo que estamos afrontando
una nueva demo ventile donde hay una
diversidad de fuerzas políticas que hoy
día estamos resultando a esta convención
constitucional y que quizás a fin de año
también se vea reflejada en las próximas
elecciones digamos del congreso
ahora hablando de diversidad de jennifer
hay ocho representantes el eje vtech y
comas que forman parte de este grupo
encargado de redactar la nueva carta
magna chilena que derechos y garantías
considera como los más fundamentales no
para este colectivo que la actual carta
magna no estaría incluyendo no
claro bueno en chile no existe ningún
tipo de norma con igualdad sustancial
solamente existe una igualdad formal y
tampoco tenemos la inclusión para el
mundo de la diversidad la verdad es que
estamos en el 5,2 por ciento de la
convención constitucional sin haber
tenido ninguna norma de
representatividad en inclusión que nos
permitiera competir de manera
diferenciada competimos igual que todos
y todas las demás y aún así logramos
entrar y nos faltaba saldar una deuda
con las compañeras trans que habiendo
estado a punto con dos compañeras no
pudieron ingresar pero hoy día creemos
que tenemos que ir a pelear con
reconocimiento por respecto por igualdad
sustancial por un valor de la diversidad
en nuestra sociedad no sólo para
nosotras nosotros y nosotros sino
también para las personas con
discapacidad por ejemplo o para las
distintas realidades que se viven en el
país y que quedan siempre excluidas pero
también queremos que el derecho a formar
familias también queremos que existan
normas de inclusión en cuanto a la
reorganización de la organización del
estado a poder participar y que basile y
que se refleje en la esta sociedad
a la diversidad que también existe hoy
día en el mundo pero también en chile no
podemos seguir siendo un país que sigue
excluyendo a toda la diversidad sexual
yo como activista legislación porque
hemos adoptado mucho pero desde los
movimientos sociales
hoy día toca reflejar este cambio a
nivel constitucional absolutamente
hablábamos no bueno de esta
representación femenina en el grupo
encargado de redactar la nueva
constitución saber que crea usted
entonces el camino quizás para abordar
temas y legislar mejor dicho temas sobre
salud reproductiva como por ejemplo nos
el derecho al aborto
absolutamente yo creo que es la
oportunidad que los ojos del mundo van a
estar puestos en nuestro país por ser la
primera constitución construida en
paridad precisamente en un país que
tiene bien poco de bari dario y bien
poco respetuoso por los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos de nos tratan
las mujeres creo que es indispensable
hoy día pongamos encima de la mesa
porque todas las mujeres feministas
tanto los derechos sexuales también los
reproductivos y también muy fuertemente
la autonomía recordar que dan sólo hace
menos de dos años ganamos la posición
del aborto terapeútico todo lo empresa
obstante en este país todo el acto de la
introducción voluntaria del embarazo se
extingue en fin es penalizado cuestión
que afecta principalmente a las mujeres
más pobres
ahora está un poco adelantada a usted al
principio de la entrevista el modelo
económico y también político de chile
estuvieron en el centro de los reclamos
de aquel estallido social no que comenzó
en octubre de 2019 cree usted que la
constitución deberá entonces incorporar
los modelos que surjan no de todo este
proceso
yo creo que sí que es indispensable el
día lo hemos levantado también desde el
mundo feminista queremos un estado
cuidador un estado garante queremos que
se supervise desea traer el estado
subsidiario que ha regido aquiles
durante los últimos 40 años y que solo
ha protegido a la clase empresarial
pospuesta por ellos para ellos y que ha
dejado al resto de la ciudadanía digamos
a su suerte y que afrontando tanto los
resultados del estallido como de la
pandemia ha resultado completamente
abandonada
por el estado y creemos que iría el
estado chileno tiene que hacerse cargo
de sus ciudadanas y sus ciudadanos sin
dejar a nadie atrás
ahora los partidos tradicionales
especialmente la coalición gobernante no
fueron por decirlo de alguna manera y
según lo han dicho muchísimos analistas
los grandes perdedores no de aquellas
jornadas del 15 y 16 de mayo no
alcanzaron ese 30 por ciento de votos
que necesitaban para bloquear cualquier
tipo de iniciativas en la carta magna-
llegaron sólo al 20 punto 56 por ciento
de los votos de que nos habla a jennifer
este resultado para los partidos
tradicionales hay una suerte de hartazgo
social en que se vayan todos digamos
yo no sé si que se vayan todos porque
las fuerzas políticas también
transformadoras y progresistas y
tuvieron un importante apoyo en esta
oportunidad creo que de lo que está
hablando es que finalmente la ciudadanía
supo elegir con mucha experiencia y
reflejar lo que fue el plebiscito del 25
de octubre del 2000 20 en los 30 por
ciento votó por una nueva constitución
por aprobarla y ese 20 por ciento yo 2
rescatarla es hoy día el mismo resultado
que obtiene la derecha que con este
tercio durante 40 años
mantuvo a más vasta democracia tutelada
este mecanismo contra mayoritario que
impedía que las las descripciones de la
gran mayoría del país pudieran hacerse
realidad
hoy día se terminó y creo que eso es una
señal muy importante para todos y todas
las chilenas es decir la invitación es a
que esa de esta minoritaria se sume a
los grandes cambios porque ya no es
necesaria que voluntaria no puede operar
su minoría contra mayoritaria y hoy día
no conviene que sea
los invitamos cordialmente a que se
sumen a estos cambios a que
efectivamente también sean parte de las
transformaciones y de los grandes
conceptos que necesita este país porque
efectivamente esa vieja forma de hacer
política
hoy día se terminó esperamos que la
nueva constitución tenga por mayoría
mucho más simplicidad que nos permitan
avanzar en los cambios que se van
produciendo en el país y no quedarnos
siempre como el país latinoamericano que
es un mal ejemplo mundial en muchas
situaciones por ejemplo el agua
privatizada un mecanismo contra
mayoritarios una serie de situaciones
que tú ves y sólo ocurrían en chile
esperamos dejar atrás esa mala
experiencia y poder de aquí en adelante
afrontar como un país desarrollado y
acuerdo los grandes cambios que
necesitamos significar nos queda poco
menos de un minuto y medio pero no
quiero dejar de preguntarle por un tema
clave en chile en la historia de chile
que es el reclamo por una educación
gratuita y de calidad no hacía un
reclamo histórico en este país de hecho
el momento de estudiantes tiene una
enorme fuerza de allí salieron
dirigentes que hoy en día son
varios de chile- gente pasa años pagando
créditos en deudas no las personas será
una prioridad de esto para la nueva
constitución
absolutamente hace más de 80 años de
abría la mistral que no sólo fue una
poetisa premio nobel sino que además fue
una de las impulsoras de la reforma
educacional en el equipo de la década de
los 30 señaló que la educación es el
alma de un pueblo y el chile no lo ha
encendido mejor nadie que los
estudiantes los y las estudiantes que
explotaron los torniquetes en octubre
del año 2019 son los y las que nos han
empujado a los grandes cambios hoy día
la educación tiene que ser el principal
motor de desarrollo de cambio en nuestro
país y para eso efectivamente tiene que
esto es primero garantizada como un
derecho especial
jennifer menciona muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en entrevista de france 24
ha sido un placer dialogar con usted
gracias a usted por favor a usted ya
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
[Música]
bien